packaging during a project in
distribution but what is a project it is
a collection of
python files that usually make up one
python package and metadata about that
package so here's where it starts to get
a little confusing I'm sorry for this
but I didn't make up the terminology a
python package is
or your source files or dot py files and
the directories that you sit inside and
they're what you import and turn into
module objects they have nothing really
to do with talk today about packaging
other than that it's going to be inside
of our distribution
so The Interpreter is what defines how
you lay out your code so it can be
imported and what it gets turned into
and we don't care what those rules are
we care about how to put it into
something that can be shared with other
developers and turns out The Interpreter
doesn't really care how we do that
doesn't care that we upload it to
ipad.org or if we ship it on floppy
disks it doesn't care how we get the job
done
so packaging is turning project into a
distribution
so what is a distribution distribution
is a single file that by itself
represents an entire
project so the python package and at
least some of the metadata that was
originally in the project
and so it's a single thing that you can
upload you can download and can be
installed and once it's installed the
python package is available for you to
use in your python code
so that's packaging so we're going to
talk about
now who does the packaging it's the
packager it's me it's you maybe maybe
you want to do packaging or you've
started to and you're not quite sure all
the choices to make
um but we're gonna go on a little story
today and we're going to start with just
the python package which is the code
and we're going to transform it into a
project
they're going to take that project and
build it into a distribution so it's the
packaging part
and then we're going to publish our
distribution so that it can actually be
used by other Developers
uh and then finally as a little bonus
we'll see how the end user actually
consumes the project even though it
doesn't really have anything to do with
the packaging
um story for the packager themselves
so this is our package for today you
know it's some python files and it's not
the simplest package it's got some sub
modules and modules and it all works
perfectly it's a great package that
everyone wants to use so
we're not going to look at it really any
further
we're going to turn it into a project
we're going to do that by stepping up
one level in the directory tree and
we've moved out of the Euro python that
is part of the package that would be the
root module you import your python
reception to the euro python folder that
is the project so it contains a package
but it also contains metadata
and all that metadata is going to be
contained in one file today pi
project.tamil
so what is the pipe project dot tunnel
it is designed to be a single location
for you to put all your metadata so you
only have to have one file
um it does a pretty good job with this
it's tool agnostic it any tools can use
it and they can share it between
different tooling and if depending on
the tools you're using besides just
packaging with other things for your
projects it could very well be the only
source of all your metadata which is
nice
um
but it's not itself a build tool Pi
Project tunnel isn't something that you
can run and it's not something that can
package for you it's just a place where
you put data so choosing to use pi
project.tomo uh is something you can do
and should do
for new projects but it's not a choice
of how to build your project
so what are we going to put inside of Pi
project.t tunnel the first thing we're
going to put in there is some build
system metadata
so we're going to have to choose a
builder because in Python unfortunately
or maybe depending on your opinion
fortunately
there's really no way to build a python
distribution these days without a
third-party dependency
the language itself can't do it for you
you have to and have something else
installed Beyond just python
and what that is is kind of a choice
you'll have to make in the end because
there are a lot of different options
but whatever you choose
consumers every package who want to
build it including machines have to know
what that choice was so you have to
write it down somewhere
and these tools are given a lot of
autonomy about how they structure
themselves and what they do so
you have to also write down the entry
points into the build system of how it
wants itself launched
so these are some of the build back ends
that we have in Python
um just a few of them there's many more
and there might be more in the future
anyone can create one and upload it to
Pi Pi as a brand new build back end
um but we're going to choose today with
our project to use setup tools kind of
it's kind of the Workhorse and one of
the oldest choices for python Packaging
so if we select setup tools
we'll take this Pi Project tunnel which
is sort of just a generic start that
doesn't have quite enough information to
build a project yet and we'll stick set
up tools specific information into it
so we'll put in that our project in
order if you want to build it you have
to have not only python but you have to
have set up tools and you have to have a
fairly recent version of it as well
and then once you have set up tools
we're telling mostly machines at this
point but we're also telling humans if
you want to actually launch setup tools
this is the object location in Python
where it contains some standard apis
that are used for building python
projects
with this uh anyone who first grabs your
project a human or a machine who doesn't
know anything about it figure out how to
build it
without having to know ahead of time
what tool you chose which is nice
so there's another section we're going
to add to Pi project.tamil which is
Project metadata
so this is all the information about
your project itself
details that will be attached to it when
it gets uploaded in distribution
some of them are important for packaging
necessary to be accepted by pipi.org or
necessary to be found by installers that
are looking for your package
some of it's not necessarily
mandatory for packaging but it's nice
information to attach to your project
things that help humans out who are
maybe searching for your project or
Discover it and want to know more about
it
um
so we're going to add a new table to the
pi project.tommel file
the project table and it contains
several entries here more than is
um necessary for Bare Bones build
but it contains a name inversion which
are pretty mandatory fields to be able
to upload to Pi Pi
um we've listed our dependencies so that
anyone who installs us knows that if you
want to use europython you must also
have EPS installed ahead of time
and then some of this other data is not
really needed by packagers or Builders
but is helpful to humans who may come
across our project
and so there's many many more Fields you
can put it in the project table they're
all listed at this
packaging.python.orglink that tells you
every field name and what types it can
take within the toml file
so back to our projects we've added
metadata so we have a proper project it
has working code and it has correct
amount of data we can build this project
now
but we said already that having a Pi
Project about Tamil doesn't add build
commands it's not executable code it's
configuration
we haven't changed any of our codes so
there's nothing to
yet
we chose a build back end
but you're not actually expected to go
into other people's pride project.tomo
and find the dependencies install them
yourself there's tools for this
so we're gonna have to look at a new
category tool called the build front end
and as you might imagine build front
ends are designed to call build back
ends and interact with each other
and they do this through an API that's
been standardized through a few pens so
that any build front end can work with
any build back end
so we're going to choose build front and
install it but we're not going to record
our choice anywhere in the project
we're not going to write down Pi
project.com or any other metadata file
and this because the choice of a build
front end is much more personal than the
choice of a build back end
whoever is the one building the project
gets to choose to build front end and
since they work with all build back ends
the author the project doesn't get to
dictate what build Finance can or will
be used they do choose the one and only
build back end that is possible to build
that project but the front end
um any one of them could build it so
we'll choose one we'll install it but
we're not going to write it down
anywhere
these are some of the build front ends
again there's a lot of choice in Python
and we have to have some third-party
module that above and beyond just the
language
so a list is actually mostly the same as
solicit build backups there's no reason
a tool can't be both
um
but even though a tool does both sides
it doesn't mean it can't be mixed up
with kind of the other ones they still
all interoperate
but uh the build backhand that we chose
setup tools uh it's very popular choice
for building for backends it's not
actually also built from it
it doesn't provide a UI to building it
doesn't work with other backends
um so we're going to have to choose a
new tool to perform this new task and
we'll install and use build as it's just
a front end and doesn't do any other
jobs
so we'll install build and once it's in
our local python environment it provides
one command line to call which is Pi
Project build we call it doesn't take
any options or arguments and it goes
ahead and does its thing reports success
it builds our project
so what did it actually do well in our
project folder we still have our package
we still have our metadata but it's
added this new dist folder with two
files inside of it
so what's up with that
um we said originally that packaging is
a process of turning a project into a
distribution
that was a bit of a fuzzy definition
actually
the process of packaging is turning a
project into multiple distributions one
or more
in this case too
so each of those files is a distribution
but we made two of them with one build
command
so there's all kinds of different
distribution formats but in Python we
have two primary ones the wheel and the
s-dist
and build went ahead and created one of
each for us
so if you're packaging python you're
going to make at least two distributions
there's always just one s disk per
version of each project but there's one
or more Wheels per version of each
project
um
this is because uh wheels are a binary
format which means that all code inside
them is pre-compiled the compilation is
done by you the packager
and then it's cheaper and faster for
users to install but you must support
all platforms all python versions
perhaps different python interpreter
types
ahead of time whereas the sdist is a
source distribution hence estist which
means you don't do any compiling you
force your users to compile on their
machine at install time
so we made one of each
and then this is the end of kind of the
action of packaging but now we want to
publish we want to actually share our
code be able for it to be discoverable
and installed by others so for this we
will need
one more type of tool which is a
publisher
um these are some of the Publishers you
need because you need another
third-party dependency to publish in
Python
um some of the names that were in the
build tool sections are still here
they're doing multiple jobs building and
Publishing but not as many do all these
jobs and the tool we chose to build
doesn't also publish Builder build just
builds
um twine is one of the most general
purpose tool for uploading distributions
so we'll install them to our local
python environment and we'll use it to
upload the distributions that were just
built
so we installed twine and it provides
this command twine and we use the upload
sub command and these two short commands
are enough to get our distribution onto
pipi.org
in reality
um the First Command isn't even strictly
necessary it's just good practice to
upload to
test.pipi.org First
and that is because it is a test
namespace of pipei.org where you can
make sure that your distributions aren't
rejected by the API for some reason and
that even when they're accepted
the project page on the website kind of
looks like you thought it would render
it has links like you thought it would
all your pictures look nice and pretty
and if you're happy with it then you can
do the real upload which by default goes
to pipi.org so you don't have to specify
that
so one or two commands and your
published on pipi.org
and that's kind of the end of the
responsibilities of you as a packager
you made your project in a distribution
and you've even shared it
um so you're kind of done at least until
you want to go make another version of
your project
but the package isn't quite done being a
package it's gone to pipi.org but if it
just sits there it hasn't done anyone
any good so to finish out its story uh
we'll take a very brief package managers
uh which kind of do a lot but quickly
you know a package manager takes a
distribution file thing you made and
kind of reinflates it from a single file
back into
potentially a directory files that you
can import into python
um
but that's not enough because we pretty
much get all our packages from someone
else's machine these days it has to also
know how to download them and it has to
know how to interact with package index
apis to find the thing you asked for
because really when you install the
package manage you ask for packages not
distribution file names so it has to
correlate the package you asked for with
a version which is probably a range of
versions and find the best fit
and once it's done that the packages
says sure I found that package at this
version that you exactly asked for but
that user uploaded eight different
distributions which one would you like
to download install
and the package manager will figure that
out and once it's done all that it then
also has to do it for all that packages
dependencies and dependencies and
dependencies and only when it's been
able to solve and find one distribution
file for each of those as I come back to
you and say yeah I was successful in
installing that thing you asked me to
so it's a lot of work but uh in the end
package managers
are the thing I download the
distribution and unpack it and put it
into your environment
so
again we have to choose a tool to do
this python natively doesn't install
packages
um
the list of tools I choose from is quite
different from the list that we started
with
back with
building
um
most tools don't go this far in the path
of package life cycle doing all the
steps poetry I think is the only one I
know of that does all of them
every other tool is kind of dropped off
the list but new ones have come up
um and our kind of favorite pip I think
everyone has run a pivot command at some
point in the python Journey
so we'll run run right now I'll pip
install Euro python would go and fetch
one of the two distributions we just
uploaded and we'll install it into our
local python environment
so we could actually import it and use
it
that's pretty great so we've kind of
done it you know
packaging has been accomplished
there was a few steps and a lot of tools
to choose from but it wasn't too hard we
transformed our package into a project
so we had to add some metadata in our
case we could add all the metadata in
one file that fit on one slide and it
was enough to build our project
but doing so we had to select a back end
we chose setup tools and then we stuck
that information in the build system
table if you chose a different back end
you would have different requirements
and a different build back end entry
point and you would have to find those
from the documentation of your chosen
tool
otherwise it would look very similar
and everywhere after we have a project
we want to build distributions from it
at least two
um
that represent our project and then we
want to so
we need a new tool for that you wouldn't
always depending on which back end you
originally chose
so we had to also install build locally
and then we could run that very simple
command
after that we had our distributions but
we wanted to share them so we needed
publishing tool and again depending on
what build system you're using you may
it will stick with the same tool or in
our case we went to Klein
and we ran two twine commands to get our
distributions onto pipi.org
and then to round it off bonus story we
saw how packages very quickly are
downloaded from a package index
and then installed into your local
system so it reinflates the distribution
and some of the metadata onto your
python path so you can import it
and that's a quick journey of how you
package and python at least for right
now
um
[Applause]
although I can't hear anything okay can
you not hear us yes I can hear you all
right so good I think if you're clapping
might be that you we have to clap louder
next time
and if there are any questions
oh
uh please come into the front uh to the
mic and
um yeah
oh he's gone
but maybe you can queue up already um if
you have any
Jeremiah are you still there yes yes
hi thank you for nice like over over
like two strawberries steps
and at each step you choose one of the
tools should we take it as a
recommendation that I don't know use
setup tools and not something else
or like was it a bread like
so yeah I mean all these tools have
trade-offs which is why you know they
all survive there's some competition
um in the packaging space
I would say the tools I laid out are
very common
um especially because I think you know
as little as four years ago and that's
kind of little in the in the history of
python if they were your only choices
uh set of tools and pip and Twine at
least kind of
predate all the others by years in most
cases so they're very popular choices
and I go with some cases
um so yes it's a bit of recommendation
it's not my workflow
for every project that I work on but
some of them it is so I'd say it's a
very common and easy to find answers if
you stick with those tools
and thanks
somebody else's syndic you can can I
have one more of course what do you
think about hedge I think it's because I
noticed that it's in your life
recommendation at like python packaging
site but I don't have experience with
that
I don't have experience either
um
yeah I haven't used it in any project
I've worked on so I'm not the best
person to ask it I think it has been
around a long time
um
but it's I've never actually seen it
used either in any of my projects or any
project I've directly uh sort of cloned
and built myself so I don't I know that
some people recommend but I don't know
who's using it
um there must be several people but
thanks
okay does anyone else have a question
otherwise I have a question for you
um we in our organization we still use
setup.py and I still have the benefit of
like calling a function instead of
people I may need to get the version
from GitHub for example
um is this is there a way to support
this also through the Domo file or how
can I get for example a version for a
distribution from GitHub
how do you do this
um
you can use Pi Project at tunnel and
keep your setup.pi RAM they can actually
coexist and they can
do so you know very well
where you can put all your static stuff
in the Pi Project Autumn and then if you
need to run one or two functions you can
just keep all the dynamic stuff inside
of that py
um so it works very well
um but the recommendation is to get
offsetup.py even if you're using setup
tools I
best if you can to just use setup.cfg if
you need something that's not supported
by the tunnel yet
um but if you need to do something
Dynamic there's not none of the other
build systems as far as I know let you
run our
arbitrary code
I'm sure some of them do
um
I guess my recommendation if you're
looking to get away from it as there are
tools
that do things like figure out your
version from a get tag or from python
code or something like this like
Virginia is one example and you can
include those other dependencies in your
build system requirements so you can put
things in there that aren't just the
exact build back end
so if you found some module that was
able to go to GitHub on your behalf and
retrieve it
and somehow insert the version into your
distribution you could add that to your
diam requirements and some hook it into
your build back end there are ways of
doing that and then so it's not you
putting arbitrary code and set up UI
it's you using a build package
um which technically is still running
arbitrary coat but it's sort of like a
hook and you build system
uh all right we have a remote question
perfect
um let's come on
[Music]
let's see if that works uh hi thank you
for the talk
um I have a question regarding the
competition that you mentioned
um so uh on the one hand you have the
PIP setup tools poetry uh ecosystem and
on the other hand you have Honda Honda
Forge member how would you compare those
ecosystems thank you
right so you're you're kind of veering
off
um from python packaging into more of
General packaging or Os level packaging
Tonda and Anaconda are very python
focused but
part of the reason that you would switch
some of your pure python or like
implementation is generally because you
need things that aren't just python code
um
or you need to link dynamically into
languages that aren't just Python and so
I mean that's kind of Advantage is that
they natively handle things that aren't
just python or C code that is directly
being turned into python extension
modules
um and you also have it so it kind of
anaconda is sort of halfway maybe even a
little closer to like an OS distribution
like you're after your um
um and so sometimes you need that but
um
yeah okay don't go there if you just
have pure python or things are just
working great in PIP but I guess do if
you're doing something that requires
packaging in languages that python
doesn't understand how to unpack and
pack
all right the next one
hello thank you for the talk
um my question uh slows a little bit
towards like the setup py question a bit
more Focus towards C extensions uh what
if we do need to do some compilation
step uh what options do we have other
than setup of UI
so
um
I've only Built extension tools using
asap.ui
so I think you can do it with Justice
setup.cfg but I'm not certain about that
um but that's definitely a reason to
choose setup tools is all of its long
support of building python extension
modules it's pretty good at
um several of the options I showed are
actually restricted it's only pure
python packages and they don't even try
to build
Seco let alone python extensions or
dynamically linked to decode
um if you want your cython like that's a
different kind of extension module
that's not pure python
um so it's definitely a reason to to
take a second look at setup tools if you
aren't already using it but some of the
other tools like nscons can build
uh C code and mature and specifically
for building rest code so if you're
trying to make a rust extension module
like
um setup tools natively doesn't work
with rust there are a set of tools rust
cross plugins now you have multiple
build time requirements you could do it
that way
but some of these back ends only work
with certain languages some of them only
python nothing else
all right I think we are through and
just on time thank you for the talk and
um for the nice q a session as well and
let's give him a very loud Applause so
that